okay Leona sadhus the [ __ ] is this we
paid up this month someone paid more
okay what happened we got arrested no to
us Burke's right we traded our dicks in
for [ __ ] that's seriously movie deals
commercials saint's name used to mean
something more than body spray and some
ass tastes an energy drink I'm brands
with a shitload of money is that what
it's all about that's always about the
money mister GATT which is precisely why
our employer wishes to speak with you if
you'll indulge us three huh
that's guys are still poor okay the [ __ ]
is this you have any idea who you're
[ __ ] with here of course I am I like
this these visions are a viola and Kiki
and I am Philip lo chairman of a
multinational organization called The
Syndicate ah never heard of it evidently
not or you would not have fought that
Bank perhaps you wonder why you're still
pleasing at this point actually I wonder
why my foots out of your ass at this
point on it yeah Randy got its hand out
like it or not mr. get our organization
is expanding into stillwater I am
offering you the chance to leverage your
assets against your lives ladies you may
continue to operate the same salt or
media group as you see fit in exchange
for sixty-six percent of your monthly
gross revenue that is before taxes of
course listen you French [ __ ] please I
embed [ __ ] so make yourself a [ __ ]
waffle we done here oh that's pretty
insane and I hurt so is about taking us
on a business arrangement
that gigantic at again
the health choice
you gotta bail no not without you
there's like half a dozen guys
I can take him what about the plane i'll
fly it back to stillwater Johnny you
can't even drive stick how you gonna fly
a plane details details and just cover
the balls go I got this
we can't leave Johnny that's fine we
have other problems attention passengers
this is your new captain speaking our
updated flight plan that has landed in
stillwater turned on me since my buns
I'd like to remind all passengers to
remain seated and enjoy the flight Mike
nice oh I can see some of us as are
getting restless Isabel exit music for
your enjoyment I love meeting new people
oh my apologies you can't do this having
troubles finding the clutch
find some shoes jump out the back it
should be clear
those are shooting at us all right well
I spelled Savage I am Belgian same thing
I am going to turn a disrespectful dog
from him Oh
oh wow
okay I like seven said yes is here oh
[ __ ]
girl states again yeah this guy a guy
okay
what assets shriman happened
Johnny we're about to jump
it is done
shadow say my papa
save my best
oh I thought that's my girl are you
serious no way to fight a lake
Oh
yes this thing is sucking and sad cube
is dancing
oh I did I left
can we look at these [ __ ] [ __ ] they
don't even have hair shifts the citizens
this is like a most insane game i ever
played oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] her Jake I
save this [ __ ] yeah where are you at
[ __ ] where you got help I look at if I
y'all trying to save your brother yeah
brother ass your sister has to back a
baby okay I got you baby let's a kiss
what's that
is gonna hit us just stay calm and don't
freak out what do you
ah I
promise you won't go cuz it gives me
later sweetie
i D
this is competent was the same thing
I've never seen anybody but actually a
lot of crazy shut hey looks like it it
got better
okay I gotta find this [ __ ] now we're
getting real life lesson oh [ __ ]
okay okay Ramos hi honey stomping cargo
Jesus
alright [ __ ] I'm gonna get you let me
say your ass mama love losses comment
[ __ ] get kinda loose here
I'm here you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] true
wow what a good memory ha
gentlemen negotiations were less than
successful july in Kiki will spread the
word still poor belongs to the syndicate
and the Saints are not welcome mr.
conveying Gaza a lucha dies and bring me
their leaders head mr. Miller hacking to
the Saints accounts and leave them
nothing what the [ __ ]
dicks out for Harambee